let's talk now about recent polling from
public policy polling this is a poll
that has been released in the middle of
Donald Trump's completely bogus and
pathetic attempts to reach out to black
voters a new PPP poll has Donald Trump
polling at 0% statistically with black
voters so first this is from the poll
Trump's favorability based on race you
will see that Trump has a 23-percent
favorability rating from Hispanic voters
a forty-one percent favorability rating
from white voters and just a dash not
even one percent statistically
favorability from black voters now there
was another question asked by the poll
which is who would you vote for given
only the options of Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump and Trump does way better
there four percent of the African
American electorate saying that they
would vote for Donald Trump 89% saying
that they would vote for Hillary Clinton
now I know PPP is a liberal polling firm
there's no doubt about that no one poll
is exactly right they all have a margin
of error but these numbers are not
drastically different than what we're
seeing in other polls were sometimes
Trump is polling three four five six
maybe seven percent favorability or
support from black voters I just can't
figure it out Jason why aren't black
voters supporting Trump all he did
recently was call them uneducated poor
people who have nothing and might as
well vote for Trump because it's
unlikely they would end up any worse off
than they already are that seems like a
great appeal to black voters well they
certainly were born but they weren't
born yesterday they they they know that
it's bunch of lies everything comes out
of everything comes out of mouth is just
a big uh you know big flaccid statement
your life is so terrible so roll the
dice on me has not been a big wave maker
in the black community and when people
hear me say oh he's polling zero that
doesn't mean there are no black people
who like Trump there's a difference
between zero people and statistically
zero in a representative sample plus or
minus three percentage points I'm not a
political consultant
but my senses what's the worst that
could happen if you vote for me is not a
really strong sort of crafted political
message I don't know if that would
convince you to vote for someone that's
where the campaign manager at this point
they're like well what what do we have
to lose this point we can say anything
we want and we're gonna get some press
and certain demographics of the American
population are still gonna vote for me
there's this implicit sort of
understanding that by some right-wingers
that the Democratic black vote is a bad
thing because it shows that Democrats
don't actually have to do anything for
minority communities because they're
just assuming the support of black
voters I find that to actually be quite
offensive to non-white voters this
includes the Latino population this
includes the black population why is the
assumption that when a population
overwhelmingly tends to support one
political party over another it's
because they don't understand the
actualities of what that party is doing
isn't it possible they've understood
that the policies of the Republican
Party are just doing nothing for them I
think it's very very offensive to imply
that there is actually nothing other
than just uh sort of optics and the
assumption of the book vote behind why
black voters overwhelmingly support
Democratic candidates I don't buy into
it whatsoever Warby Parker is offering a
free five day home try-on to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses i personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial dot-com / tdps I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for
a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing